After so many hours of use,
our trash can metal foundry is falling apart.
So in today's video,
we'll be making an upgrade using
a new bucket and some fire brick.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
This is a type of brick made from a silica
that is designed to withstand a lot of heat.
This is very similar to the
type of brick as found inside kilns
designed for firing
ceramics and similar things.
And we want to try and use
this kind of brick
to line and protect the
inside of our foundry.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll draw up some patterns for
the inside of this foundry,
and cut our fire bricks into shape so
they fit nicely around the edges.
We'll use Kaowool to fill in any gaps,
and to line the lid.
The Kaowool will be attached to the lid
using some stainless steel hardware.
As with our previous designs,
we'll have two holes in the sides,
and two holes in the top.
Now, I chose this bucket
because it's a great size.
It seems like it has a pretty
solid handle on it and it's got a lid.
All of those things are necessary.
However,
you can see that this bucket is black,
and that's not the normal
color of the steel.
This has been powder coated.
That powder coating will burn off
probably the first time we fired it up,
so just to get ahead of things,
we're going to take a torch
and burn it all off right now.
It's not going to look
as pretty afterward,
but it will work well.
[Music]
It's taking me a while to burn all of
the paint off using our small propane torch,
so what I'm going to try is to
drill the two holes that I know
I need in the sides of my bucket,
hook up the large propane tank,
and then just let it burn with
no insulation in there at all.
That should heat the
whole thing up really nicely,
and burn off all the excess paint,
and then we can continue on from there.
I probably need to change the height
of where our burners enter our furnace.
In the past, we had a pretty
thin bottom on here,
and this time, I think we're going
to use a half of one of these bricks,
which is going to be about
an inch and half thick.
So that's going to stick up a little bit
more than what we've used before.
So I have a mark where it was before,
let's go up to about right there.
[Music]
While I'm cutting holes in metal,
might as well cut the
holes in the lid as well.
[Music]
It's probably inevitable,
that at some point, this handle is
going to burn up.
But I might be able
to prolong that just a little bit.
[Music]
This is going so much faster.
I think we are just about there.
Beautiful.
Well, I mean it's ugly.
But how well it worked was beautiful.
Now, we just need to give this
a few minutes to cool off.
While our metal bucket is cooling down,
and before we clean it
off and do the next steps,
we're going to take some of these
fire bricks and cut them down.
We want the bottom to be about
half of one brick,
and the sides,
we're going to try and cut
these bricks into thirds.
So we have about 1 inch slices.
[Music]
All right. I suspect this is going to make
more dust than pretty much anything
I've ever done before,
so I'm going to do it outside,
and I'm going to be wearing a dust mask.
This fire brick is really fragile stuff.
It's so full of air that it doesn't
have nearly the structural strength
of regular bricks.
But one advantage of that is that you
can cut it really easily with just a hand saw.
[Music]
Just because you can cut it easily,
doesn't mean you can cut it well.
So I have to be really careful
to cut in nice straight lines,
or I'm going to end up with two pieces
that are wildly different thicknesses.
[Music]
Not bad.
It's not 100% perfect,
but that is pretty close
to a nice flat base.
I like it.
Now, we've got to cut
two more bricks into thirds.
This is a million times better in the shade.
[Music]
Now, in the past,
when we've made these foundries,
we have used a galvanized steel bucket.
Not one of these black powder coated ones.
And I was trying to switch to
something that was steel,
but not galvanized steel.
Honestly, I'm not sure if this worked or not,
the label just said that it was steel.
It didn't specify whether
it was or was not.
The main reason is that
galvanized steel puts off fumes
that you really don't want to breathe in
when it gets heated up too much.
I always try and avoid the fumes
when I've got my foundry running.
I just like to stand upwind of it,
and not be breathing in
whatever it's putting off.
So I don't think that really affects
one way or the other too badly.
I just thought I would try,
and if I can get a
non-galvanized steel one,
I'd use that.
We're going to be using these two bricks,
which is one brick cut in half as
the very base for our foundry.
However, as you can see they are
larger than the base at the moment,
so we need to trim them down.
So to cut them down to just the right size,
we're going to measure the size
of the bottom of our bucket,
trace a circle out that same size,
place our bricks on top of that,
and line up where we need
to make some cuts
so they fit nicely into
the bottom of the bucket.
Excellent.
Let's go trim those corners.
[Music]
All right.
Let's see if this fits or if we need
to do a little bit more trimming.
[Music]
That fits.
That should give us a nice solid base.
That will do a great job insulating heat,
and not go anywhere.
This firebrick stuff should withstand
quite a bit of stress testing.
Now, we do have a
slightly slant wall bucket,
so measuring the diameter of the
height above the base
gives us approximately 10 inches.
Because now, what we need to do
is take our six 1-inch pieces of brick,
and cut those so that they will
all fit down inside our bucket,
providing some walls.
[Music]
You can see the idea of
how we want these bricks to go,
but they don't fit super
nicely right now
because they're just a little
bit too wide in places.
So we got to figure out just
how much to trim those
to make them all fit in nicely together.
Shouldn't take too much trimming,
I don't think.
To get those measurements,
instead of just cutting up
actually pieces of brick,
we're going to trace out pieces of
this foam with the same dimensions
of one end of the brick,
and lay them out on this circle.
That should let us see
how much they overlap
and what needs to be trimmed.
[Music]
By lining these six pieces
up around in a circle,
we can see how much overlap we have,
and that gives us a pretty good
idea of what we need to cut.
[Music]
You can see that by trimming off
the corners of all six pieces,
we should get something that
fits nicely together,
and backs right up against the
very edges of the bucket.
So what we need to do is
take down these long corners
to match up with what we've
cut out of the foam here.
And to do that, I'm going
to try using a belt sander,
and boy, I thought sawing these
was going to be dusty,
I think the belt sander
is going to put that to shame.
We'll see how well it does.
[Music]
They may have gotten trimmed
a little bit more than necessary,
but do all fit together,
and I think we can make this work.
We need to be able to pass our torch
heads through two of the brick panels,
one on each side.
Let's cut those holes.
[Music]
I think it's time to add in our kaowool.
We're going to use that to fill in some
of the gaps around the sides,
and hold the fire bricks just
where we want them.
And as I said,
we'll use them to line the lid.
[Music]
In the past,
we've had our kaowool stuck
to the lid using just friction,
and that works pretty well for a while.
As the Kaowool degrades,
it starts to be a little bit smaller and
lose some of its structural integrity.
At which point, it starts to just falling out.
So as an upgrade,
we're going to do something,
like we did with our giant metal foundry,
and we're gonna use some stainless
steel hardware to hold that all in place.
[Music]
Now, I have an idea for
how I want this to go,
and I'm actually going to install these
bolts with the head down inside of the lid,
and my goal is to sort of
make a couple of little feet
that I can have sticking
down on the bottom,
so when I remove the lid off of the foundry,
I can just set it down,
and the bolts will just
hold it off of the ground.
[Music]
Hey, that's standing.
All right. Let's see if this works.
Now, those might be long enough at
this point that they hit the fire brick inside,
but if they are, we can just
adjust them so they're shorter.
[Music]
I think that works out nicely.
It fits within the kaowool barrier,
and does not quite reach the brick.
So, we've now got a lid that goes down on.
The kaowool should be able to stay on,
even after it gets old and start
losing some of its integrity,
and when we want to remove our lid,
we can just set it down,
and it stays off of the ground.
The kaowool doesn't hit the dirt.
I don't have to worry about
flipping it over,
and being quite so careful with it.
I can just set it down,
and that will hold itself up.
We've got the bricks lining
the bottom and the sides,
we've got kaowool holding the
bricks right where we want,
and insulating the top.
I think all that we need now
is to test this bad boy.
Let's get some propane going around in it.
See how it does.
[Music]
I like that feature.
Of course, the real test is going to be
seeing how well this holds up over time.
I'm pretty sure that the bricks are going
to do a better job than just kaowool,
of staying intact,
and not starting to fall to pieces.
Stay tuned for future videos to see
how it holds up under stress.
Guys, its not over yet.
There's more for you to see.
If you missed our last video
and need to see it again,
the box up at the top will
take you right there.
The box at the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you need to do watching now,
and this bomb in the middle will
subscribe you to the channel,
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.